GAME.
RONDO.
IT IS DAVIS.
11 AND 20.
DOUBLES AND SPINS OUT.
GETS IT TO TOSCANO-ANDERSON.
REBOUND.
FIRST TIME HE HAS BEGUN A SEASON
WITH A CONFIRMED SLOT ON A
ROSTER.
HE HAD TO FIGHT AND CLAW HIS WAY
TO THE NBA.
CURRY, QUICK RELEASE, THREE, NO.
CURRY FELL.
>> Reggie: FELL.
THERE WAS MOISTURE OVER THERE.
>> Kevin: THE SHOT GOES DOWN.
GOOD SHOT BY MALIK MONK WITH THE
THREE.
AND SOMEONE SPILLED SOMETHING ON
THE FLOOR.
CURRY WIPING HIS HANDS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO KEEP THE
BEVERAGES AT BAY.
IS IT THAT GUY WITH NO MASK?
LOOK AT THESE --
>> Reggie: THAT HAPPENED RIGHT
IN FRONT OF FLOYD MAYWEATHER,
THE CHAMP.
>> Kevin: WHO IS GOING TO ARGUE
WITH HIM.
CURRY MUST HAVE KNOCKED THAT
OVER.
CURRY IS GOING TO GO TO THE
BENCH.
>> Reggie: IT IS ALL OVER HIS
SHOES AS WELL.
>> Kevin: LET'S WATCH IT AGAIN.
>> Reggie: THE QUICK TRIGGER
HERE BY STEPH.
INTO THE LAP AS HE STARTS TO
HEAD ON UP.
YEAH.
IT IS SLIPPERY OVER THERE.
MOISTURE.
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE ANYTHING
SPILLED OVER THERE.
>> Kevin: AND A CUT.
>> Reggie: AND A CUT, YEAH.
>> Kevin: I HAVE BEEN TOLD THIS
IN THE FIRST HALF, KERR WAS
RAVING ABOUT THE CONDITION.
HE SAID IT IS NOT JUST WHAT HE
SHOWED IN CAMP BUT HIS BUILD UP
TO WHERE HE WAS WHEN HE GOT TO
CAMP.
AND STEVE SAID, YOU KNOW, HE
JUST ADMIRES HIM ON SO MANY
LEVELS.
HE IS 33.
ALL-TIME LEADING WARRIORS
SCORER.
LED THE LEAGUE IN SCORING LAST
SEASON.
>> Reggie: I HAD A CHANCE TO
SPEAK WITH HIM LAST WEEK.
HE IS ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT THE
EVOLUTION OF HIS BODY.
BECOMING A BETTER SHOOTER.
>> Kevin: IN HIS GAME, TOO.
>> Reggie: I SAID YOU AVERAGED
32 POINTS.
YOU WERE THIRD IN THE MVP
VOTING.